[Music]
we're going to talk a bit about sort of
the difference between American and UK
media that sort of balance between
alternative media and mainstream media I
thought I just sort of introduced myself
a little bit and then asked you to
introduce yourself in case there's
people on that channel who aren't
familiar with you so my my background
like I work for Channel four News for
many years in the UK and then the BBC
and then made documentaries for several
years so I've worked in a newsroom in
the mainstream media swith what you
probably call the the liberal mainstream
media and also for the last year and a
half or so I've been I've been sort of
delving more deeply into YouTube after
setting up rebel wisdom the the YouTube
channel so I kind of had a bit of a
steep learning curve in terms of seeing
the difference between the two but it's
been a really interesting journey and
sort of producing documentaries and
films on on YouTube and can you tell me
a bit about your background and and what
you've maybe a little bit of what you've
learned doing it over the last however
many years
sure so now I host the David Pakman show
which is a multi-platform independent
progressive show based in the u.s.
multi-platform meaning that the program
is on radio stations it's on television
stations it's on satellite TV on a
channel called free speech TV and then
independently we also have an online
presence with a YouTube channel and an
audio podcast and in in terms of how
it's changed I mean of course on on the
technical side it's changed and I hope
for the better as you know my production
team has expanded and gotten more more
tech-savvy and technology has continued
to improve and become more accessible
but I think from from a sort of
perspective point of view at the
beginning I would tend to do much more
of the on the one hand on the other hand
sort of presentations and I realized
that that was both not particularly
interesting to me that I really wanted
to be giving my opinion my point of view
and it also wasn't super interesting to
the audience because
it was you know either way there are
going to be people who disagree and I
might as well just do the best job I
kind of advocating for what I sort of
think is best or the best policy so I
think over time the program has
certainly become more more opinionated
than it started as I'd love to return to
that a bit later on because there is
this sense that this this kind of view
from nowhere affectation that the
mainstream media has has been shown up
quite a lot by the growth of alternative
media as being as being an affectation
like there is no view from nowhere and I
think that's becoming really much more
clear one of the reasons that I was
really keen to talk to you David was I I
did I wasn't
I confess I wasn't that aware of your
show until I sort of diving into my
preparation for my interview with Dave
Rubin and I I I saw that I think one of
the things in the online media space at
the moment is it's very easy to get
caught in reality tunnels it's very easy
to end up giving your audience what you
want and I could see that at times you
take an unpopular the unpopular
perspectives with your audience and that
you seemed willing to engage with people
from all over the political spectrum but
from a from what I could see from a very
good faith perspective and being willing
to to say things that might make you
unpopular is that is that have that
could you tell me about some of those
occasions that have that have happened
on your channel and why has that
happened do you think well I mean I
think certainly everything I say is
unpopular with someone I think maybe
what you're getting at is sometimes
there have been stories where there was
more of a backlash from what I guess I
would perceive to be maybe my core
progressive audience you know -
generally well to the left of someone
like Hillary Clinton or Joe Biden but
still probably to the right of actual
socialists and communists so to speak so
some somewhere in there and in the sort
of world of social democracy and you
know my principle has been and going
back to the first thing we talked about
in kind of explaining to you the
philosophy of my show and how I've
gotten away from this idea of
on the one hand on the other hand the
view from nowhere and just really doing
every story the way I see it I recognize
that you're never going to see eye to
eye on every issue with any particular
person I mean with people that I
consider to be my strongest political
allies there there still can be areas of
disagreement and they're almost always
are so the approach that I've taken to
just do every story the way I see it
regardless of the consequences is based
in I just want to be genuine right and
if I start moderating and by moderating
I don't mean moving to the middle but I
mean being a moderator of my own speech
on the basis of what I think the
audience reaction will be it's it's
actually potentially a slippery slope I
don't want to get into and I'm always
cautious of slippery slopes when I don't
think they apply but that actually could
be a slippery slope I don't want to get
into so for example there was a recent
story in the United States about a
congresswoman named Alan Omar where she
made some comments related to the Israel
lobby and there were a number of
perspectives on what she said ranging
from it was downright evidence of her
personal anti-semitism all the way to
the other side of it was a perfect
analysis that was in no way tinged with
anti-semitism and I took what I knew
would be a position that some of my
audience would disagree with or or take
issue with but I decided to take it
anyway you know if I looked at my
YouTube analytics I probably had a net
loss of subscribers as a result of doing
that story and that's okay and I think
that my perception is that most of the
audience that is supporting me
financially is supporting me not because
they expect that they're going to agree
with me on every issue but because they
can trust that I'm going to be genuine
with them about every issue and not
calculate my perspective on the basis of
what I think will be appealing to the
people that are watching me if that
makes sense we're in a media environment
that really doesn't reward nuance it
seems absolutely and on all of these
issues very often the most
controversial issues where maybe my
audience and I have clashed my core
audience as I as I would call them our
issues where if you ignore the nuance
that I'm at least attempting to present
and sort of make a caricature of my
position you really are completely
missing the point that I'm making so
another example would be Venezuela
Venezuela has been one that I'm
particularly interested in as an
immigrant from Argentina to the United
States and someone who sort of grew up
in a house where Latin America and South
American politics were a topic of
significant discussion I have made every
attempt to sort of make very clear
whenever Venezuela comes up and the
Maduro Chavez regimes come up to make
very clear that I'm against American
intervention in Venezuela I'm against
you know military involvement by the
United States and Venezuela that
historically American involvement in
that region of the world has been
disastrous for for the region for the
people of the region but that as a non
authoritarian leftist I am NOT a
supporter of Shafa I was not a supporter
of Chavez I am NOT a supporter of Maduro
and unfortunately the reaction from many
of those in my core audience is David
how dare you support the United States
putting a puppet president in Venezuela
which of course is not an argument that
I'm making so and that's not even
particularly nuanced right I mean from
my point of view it's I don't like the
regime and I don't think it should be
the United States that gets involved in
replacing it it to me it's it's barely
nuanced but unfortunately in an
environment that doesn't seem to take
super kindly to the on the one hand on
the other hand sort of thing I've
definitely suffered as a result of
taking those positions I'm really
interested in in reflecting on a few
recent piece or a few recent media
encounters that showed up sort of some
of the culture clash between alternative
and mainstream and also UK in the u.s.
maybe starting with the sort of very
high profile
clash between Andrew Neil on the BBC and
Ben Shapiro why don't you just say that
you're on the left it's so hard for you
why can't you just be honest this is a
it's a serious question
mr. Shapiro if you only knew how
ridiculous that statement is you
wouldn't have said it so let's move on
absolutely yeah I mean so is there a
particular I mean do you want to get my
general sense of it so to speak yeah why
don't why don't you why don't you sketch
out what you made of it from there I
mean how familiar with the iewk because
it seemed that Ben Shapiro in particular
wasn't very familiar with UK
journalistic styles which is very
combative very sort of devils advocate
questioning and he seemed to completely
misunderstand and quite amusingly for a
british purse British Watcher because
Andrew Neil is famously right-wing he
accused Andrew Neil of being clearly a
left-wing interviewer yeah I thought
that there were you know that my
analysis I I maybe am more familiar with
that style than at least ben shapiro
appeared to be during that particular
interview although my familiarity with
with Andrew Neil was was limited
although I was generally aware of him as
a as a conservative individual
personally so I wasn't so surprised by
the interviewing style my surprise was
really maybe as you're hinting at the
way that ben shapiro handled it who
within the context of the united states
and often in particular during these
events that he does at colleges and
universities where he's being questioned
primarily by by college students
effectively there's this idea that he's
never rattled and that his mind operates
so quickly and that you can't trick him
in any way and that he's always one step
ahead and ready with the sort of most
powerful brutal refutations as many
YouTube clip titles like to point out so
I was most surprised by the way that he
was so thrown off by the way the
interview was going and then it got very
quickly to where you know two principles
that ben shapiro espouses almost to a
level of satire in the United States are
this idea of facts don't care about your
feelings and also being very much
against so-called identity politics as
the
in a sort of very particular way and
where it kind of broke down was that
been violated both of those ideas right
his incorrect perception of the identity
of the interviewer caused him to sort of
cut it short on the basis that this
progressive left-wing whatever term you
want to apply to the interviewer was not
interviewing him in good faith or was
employing some kind of gotcha questions
or however you you want to analyze it
one of his principles in the context of
how he's known in the u.s. is that
identity is not relevant in situations
like this that it's all about what are
the facts and in a sense his feelings
sort of got the best of him his feelings
overrode the facts which were the the
questions posed to him by the
interviewer and the reality that the
interviewer was actually a conservative
personally not not on the left so that
was the what was so interesting to me
that someone who is known in the US as
being sort of unshakably principled in
identity doesn't matter it's all about
the facts it's all about reality
abandoned that as he was very rattled by
the way that the interview was carried
out yeah I mean this is a good time to
to mention Dave Rubin so I went I
interviewed Dave Rubin a bit over a
month ago now and put their interview
out probably two weeks ago something
like that and I I first found out about
the intellectual dark web through Dave
Reubens show and so I was sort of very I
guess I was i admired a lot of the
conversations that I'd seen on the show
and I haven't paid a huge close
attention to the other interviews that
he'd done and then in the research for
the interview that I did with Dave I dug
up quite a bit of stuff that made that
that gave me a few concerns and I knew
that going in for my own sort of self
respect as a journalist I had to ask
some more probing questions the
criticisms that I see any of you that I
think have some some validity is
sometimes you draw this you talk about a
new center evolving but you draw that
new center around some
people that that I would consider on the
right let Stefan Stefan modern you for
example well I've never said that stefan
molyneux xin the new center i really
have you ever heard me say that i
thought you had know another example
would be the Katie Hopkins interview
yeah and Katie Hopkins I mean I know
Katie Hopkins pretty well coming from
the UK and the way that that interview
was framed was that she was sort of
being shut down for in a politically
correct way but the actual article that
she wrote was calling for gunboats to be
used against migrants and compared them
to cockroaches right so so the interview
was about two years ago I actually don't
remember every specific instance of the
interview I mean that's just that's just
the truth I see I mean this is one of
the strange things it's like everyone
calls for more tolerance we should talk
to people we should interview people we
should sit down with people but then the
second you actually do it then you're
the enemy I don't think I'd ever argue
that you shouldn't sit down with someone
I think my main point is whether people
are being challenged enough right so as
I said earlier they look the bigger you
get the more relevant you get the more
haters are gonna come out but the more
that legitimate criticism will come out
- and again I address this all the time
what do you think's the most legitimate
criticism it's not really for me to say
what the legitimate criticism of me if
someone wants to say that they don't
like the way I interview or that I don't
ask hard enough questions or something
like that
well I suppose that is a legitimate
criticism of me it's not the way I like
doing my business and you know if you
don't like what I'm doing then I would
say you don't have to watch it doesn't
mean I'm doing it perfectly I mean one
of the reasons I got in touch as well is
that this has started happening more and
more at Dave Reubens events that there
are people who are asking him why won't
you talk to Tantra points why won't you
talk to Carl kolinsky why won't you talk
to Sam sida why won't you talk to David
Pakman and I know recently as well that
he he said on stage that you'd lied
about him or he gave a reason why he
wasn't going to to be interviewed by you
or to interview me I guess it was yeah
he said Pacman's lied about me I think
it was a bunch of times or many times or
something like that I still you know if
that's the case then I really want to
know what what those lies or you know I
would argue that they wouldn't really
he lies they might be miss statements
which I very well might have made about
dave rubin i just don't know what they
are I haven't heard so far I mean listen
my my perspective is so I'm not a
journalist per se Dave Rubin is not a
journalist we are doing programs that
are commentary interview analysis call
it sort of what you want so you know my
primary criticism of the way that Dave
Rubin has carried out of interviews are
sort of there's two criticisms one is I
think that left-wing voices outside of
the so-called intellectual dark web have
been mostly excluded now I know that
recently there were assertions made that
Dave has interviewed I don't know if he
said it was socialists and communists or
lefties and communists or something like
that that may be true I don't I don't
know who those folks are and I'd be
interested in knowing about that but I
think generally speaking if what you
don't have to give equal voice to all
sides of the political spectrum that's
totally fine not to but I think that if
you are sort of asserting that there is
a sort of open-door policy to all sorts
of ideas then I think it would be best
to more equally represent ideas from a
variety of sort of placements on the
political spectrum so that's been one of
my criticisms and you know we I
tentatively at one point was going to be
appearing on on Dave's new program and
then it didn't happen and it's not
completely clear to me exactly why and I
think at this point I don't have the
open invitation that at one point I did
so I would be glad to be one of those
people and I would be glad for others to
be those folks you know my particular
interest in this is that I used to be
relatively friendly with Dave and we
used to text and have phone calls with
some sporadic regularity I guess it
would be the term I would apply to it
and since I interviewed him on my
program for an hour we've had almost no
communication and there's been what I
perceive to be sort of like a cutting of
what was at one point a very cordial and
friendly relationship and I don't know
why that is I don't know
he's never expressed that he wasn't
happy with how the interview with me
went where I did go into policy in the
way that I like to healthcare taxation
etc so that's sort of my personal
interest in it as far as the one other
thing I'll say is as far as the
interview style yes I've been critical
of giving a platform and that's the term
I use and I don't use it
pejorative ly when you have a platform
and you invite someone to it you are
sharing that platform with the other
person I take special care because of
how I manage my show where if I am
platforming someone whose ideas I
perceive to be extreme dangerous
discriminatory problematic I make sure
that I'm responsibly platforming them
which includes both being prepared to
take on what I perceive to be bad
arguments and not being afraid to make
clear that I disagree with some of those
arguments or positions I would like to
see Dave do that and as I've told him
personally he can kind of manage those
interviews however he wants but it's not
how I would feel good about handling
some of those interviews now the reason
maybe he doesn't feel comfortable being
that adversarial that would be perfectly
fine the reason may be that he agrees
with those things that maybe I see as
problematic positions or some other
reason I don't know what the reason is
but it's not how I would sort of run my
program if there are critiques out there
of Dave Rubin or whoever which are
limited to this is a person who is doing
something wrong because of the political
orientation of their guests period that
is guilt by association and it's it's
also just not really a serious critique
I think that my critique of the
instances or the episodes of the Dave
Rubin program that I have made focus on
number one do I believe that there is
irresponsible platforming taking place
with regard to if there are known bad or
incorrect ideas or ideas that are
discriminant
taury ideas that are xenophobic or
whatever is the interviewer well enough
prepared to push back against those and
whether or not I mean you can be
prepared and still choose not to push
back I don't think that that is
responsible platforming I don't think
that that serves any serious
journalistic or cultural purpose most
people who sort of exist in the West and
have access to the Internet and to media
know that xenophobia exists that white
supremacy exists that anti-semitic
conspiracies exists so on and so forth
and I don't understand the value of
merely giving someone a platform to
espouse those ideas so what I'm for is
responsible platforming I have
interviewed all sorts of right-wing
people people with really disgusting
views but the only way that I feel good
about it about doing it is if it's made
abundantly clear that is I disagree with
these horrible ideas and I'm prepared to
push back against them so to the extent
that Dave Rubin has done interviews for
example with folks like Brigitte Gabriel
where she actually touts anti-semitic
conspiracy theories and Dave doesn't
push back against it that's what my
critique is of it's not of the fact that
he interviewed someone who's a right
winger I completely agree that's not
really a good criticism it's not a
productive one and it's not going to I
mean listen we the left should engage
with the right the right if it wants to
should engage with the left but it needs
to be done in a responsible way and
that's my approach to it since the
interview that I did with Dave Rubin
there have been quite a few pieces on
various left-leaning channels about him
not just off because of my interview
although Sam cedar did pick it up and
run something on my interview and I get
a sense of almost like a feeding frenzy
around him at the moment and is that
something that you're picking up I'm
picking it up as well I think it's
gotten momentum and I think that there
has been sort of because of the you know
that there's no better way to get
something discussed on a bunch of
YouTube channels than to mention the
names of the hosts of those YouTube
channels to some of these people that
have shown up at Dave's event
and said hey what about David Pakman or
Sam cedar or contra points that's a
great way to get that story onto those
shows for better or worse but I do think
you know listen what's going on with
Dave Rubin is not uniquely bad I think
it's a combination of sort of a a an
audience capture sort of dynamic
combined with a predisposition from many
of these internet enclaves to really
adhere to the type of content that sort
of is de-facto produced on Dave's
channel and I think that there is a bit
of a feeding frenzy going on and I'm
sort of trying to be careful not to
devolve into the ad homonyms to restate
that I think he and I could have a
really great conversation which I
maintain my openness to participate in
and sort of leave it at that I also want
to sort of take it out a little bit to
say so he's obviously been being
challenged quite a bit and there's
there's quite a lot of critiques of Dave
out there already and it this seems to
be a feature of the polarized landscape
as well I know like the Sam cedar for
example and I think Michael Brooks on
Sam cedar show there's quite a lot and
Ana and Ana Kasparian as well there's
quite a lot of critiques of Dave that in
a way I can see that the audience of
those shows wants people to beat up on
Dave Rubin so that becomes so the tone
of those critiques seems to become more
and more cognitive and then the chances
for any kind of dialogue are the chances
of Dave sort of being able to say well
yeah I'll let out I'll welcome these
people onto my show then seems to to
deteriorate massively because of the
tone of those critiques do you see what
I mean like that polarization seems to
make good faith dialog even more
difficult absolutely I mean on the one
hand why are some of these voices not
being interviewed by Dave Rubin but on
the other hand I completely see why he
would not be inclined to bring voices on
that are sort of levying harsher and
harsher criticisms against him in terms
of
their tone as it goes sort of like above
and beyond the fact so that's why I've
you know I have a track record that is
not something to brag about it's just a
reality of being able to have civil
conversation with almost anybody now
sometimes when I say that people will
write to me and say David it's no big
accomplishment to be able to calmly talk
to Nazis right and it's not I'm not
citing it as an accomplishment in that
sense I mention it in order to be able
to say although I have these differences
with Dave Rubin or with whoever with Ben
Shapiro or name anybody if we decide hey
we're going to sit down and really
figure out where do we agree where do we
disagree what are the lines of this sort
of this debate assuming that it doesn't
evolve into personal attacks against me
I'm gonna have no problem carrying that
out in a civil way we're really the
focus is going to be substance rather
than a tax or tone or whatever so I've
tried to make it clear that these are my
disagreements with Dave Rubin in terms
of what he's putting out on online but I
would sort of relish the opportunity to
respectfully figure out where is he
coming from on these things you know the
last conversation I had with him as I
mentioned was this hour interview I did
with him at this point it might be two
years ago or more so I completely
understand why as people become more
sort of virulent in their critiques why
he would be disinclined to allow them to
participate on his program that being
said I also am unsure why someone for
example who is openly homophobic or
anti-semitic which relates to two you
know identities that that Dave Rubin is
part of why they would be I see that I
see platforming that without serious
challenges just as problematic as sort
of keeping out broad swaths of the
political spectrum yeah there is
something quite ironic I I find in in
what's going on at the moment and I'm
bringing in sort of Ben Shapiro here as
well in in his criticisms of Andrew Neil
and that there is almost a mirror image
of what they accuse the left or social
justice warriors
of doing of tone policing of no
platforming of pre deciding that a
conversation is not going to be
constructive and that feels very ironic
like that there is something very that
there is there is something that's very
similar about those two perspectives
yeah and I'd love to have the
opportunity to really explore that in in
in some detail for sure I mean being
against identity politics but then
making identity arguments or being
against sort of limiting the scope of
voices or the ideas that are heard but
then not sort of actively pursuing more
diversity of voices in in those ways and
you know I do think that in it without
inviting me on anyone's program I think
that there would be a very interesting
conversation to have with whether it's
Dave or whether it's Ben Shapiro or
whoever about what I perceive to be a
contradiction as far as that goes and
I've made some video clips on my channel
about those those apparent
contradictions and I think it would be a
great conversation to have and it would
not be a bad faith conversation I mean I
genuinely am interested in if someone
says identity politics is bad how do
they justify making identity arguments
you know I feel as though my view on
identity politics is relatively nuanced
which is using identity as a sort of
cudgel to suppress voices and to say
only those who check a certain box
should be listened to or primarily
should be the ones listen to I'm against
that but it would also be ignorant to
ignore the reality that one's identity
relates to their experience in the world
and thus there may be some special value
or particular value in considering that
when we are exploring what we should be
doing as humans on this planet in terms
of figuring out the problems that face
us are you familiar with Jonathan
heights work very much so yes and I've
interviewed him in read recently read
the there is it the righteous mind the
coddling of the American mind is the
most recent one the righteous mind is
about how good people are divided by
politics that's the one I read yeah yeah
I mean I think his work is absolutely
crucial
- - understanding if if political belief
is largely based on temperament then we
have to keep talking to each other and
the separation into armed camps which is
what seems to be happening through the
kind of WL sense-making WMV of social
media seems to be one of the most
existential threats that we're we're
facing absolutely and privately I've
been talking to a lot of people about
what are some techniques that have
actually been able to sort of open the
door to these cross party lines
conversations and there you know are
some specific techniques that I've come
across which I think are useful which
I'm glad to talk about but maybe are not
really the scope of our conversation
today but I do believe that there are
lots of ways that these conversations
can happen and I think it's undeniable
that social media is not facilitating
any of that I'd certainly be interested
if you were able to run through them
fairly quickly yeah I mean just a couple
of ideas and some of these I employ them
on my program when I have adversarial
callers I mean one thing is a great
basis for a conversation between people
who disagree is asking the other person
to sort of read back to you or to
explain to you what do they perceive
your position to be and maybe more
importantly why do they think you've
arrived at that position so for example
healthcare debates can be
extraordinarily divisive just to take an
issue like that I am on the left and I
believe that some sort of single-payer
nationalized or otherwise universal
system is the way forward although I'm
relatively agnostic about the specifics
rather than just like diving into a very
heated conversation about that with
someone who thinks the market system is
best if I ask them listen you know my
position why do you think I have my
position how do what what what led me to
arrive at my position if they are good
faith participants which will be very
quickly exposed by a question like that
merely by reading back to me why they
think I believe what I believe they are
going to be significantly predisposed to
listen to my ideas because they are
probably going to attribute good faith
reasons to how I
arrived at my conclusion they might say
well listen you probably think it's the
most efficient way to get the best care
to the most number of people if someone
just says that that is instantly
changing the tone and the tenor of the
conversation away in a way that I think
is very positive I tend to follow that
up with given your position on this
issue
what evidence if I was able to present
it to you would would change your mind
and this is something I first heard from
Peter Boghossian the DES feasibility
test although I've seen it from others
as well just those two questions to set
up a conversation about most political
issues will significantly include the
chances of it being productive and maybe
of actually making some progress on
these issues it's interesting so we as I
said we featured the intellectual dart
web quite a lot and there's some talk
about what it is and whether there could
be a kind of IDW protocol for good-faith
conversation that that and that I think
could be part of it I think Steele
Manning is something there at Weinstein
talks about which is kind of what you're
talking about in your what you were just
saying is can you restate back to me my
own argument in a way that I'll agree
with I I think that there's definitely
significant overlap in the ideas yeah
from my perspective sort of I'm thinking
about what is the the other side of the
culture war dynamic that we're looking
at and I think it is something like
appreciating that everyone has values
that are important and Jonathan heights
work I think is really perfect for this
to show that there are five moral
tastebuds liberals are more sensitive to
two of them conservatives are more
sensitive to the others and that also
that there's a sense that any ID or any
any set of values when taken to an
extreme can become an ideology and then
you're in some sense you're divorced
from an evolutionary conversation at
that point in that you can't really
engage with anyone else because you've
fixated your values into an ideology I
think that's right in the last year and
a half or two years one of the most
valuable experiences I had when it comes
to this is I actually went
to rural northern Indiana in the Midwest
of the United States which is real Trump
country its church country and it's gun
country I mean it's basically a place
where you drive down these country roads
and the only things you pass are gun
ranges and churches and in spending some
time there and in talking to people I
understand why they voted for Trump
I understand how abortion becomes this
voting issue for large swaths of the
country
I understand how guns sort of take on
the cultural significance that they do
for many people in the United States it
didn't change my views but it definitely
changed my perspective on oh yeah I
actually understand how if this is the
environment you grow up around you end
up with the political views that seem
totally antithetical to my sort of
northeastern United States cosmopolitan
views and it was an extraordinarily
enlightening experience particularly in
making me think about what are the best
and wait I still think that they're
wrong on policy but how can I better
engage with them on those issues great
David thank you very much for for making
the time my pleasure it was so great to
speak to you
[Music]
you
[Music]